PowerPoint PowerPoint PowerPoint
PowerPoint pleas put together a
presentation for financial recovery
great you may find it very informative
let's get started with our first
slide well well
well you blew it super hard complete
buffoonery it's hilarious and you
deserve it hey you think you might want
to take it easy on them a little bit oh
like they took it easy on us when they
stole all our money and seceded from our
town it was 200 years ago cool it fine
I'll skip ahead do you have a plan that
will help us or not we have borrowed
absolutely everything we can from the
state and really Pony is our only hope
we do have a plan we are willing to
provide a bridge loan for
$50,000 25% interest compounded monthly
and you need to release a statement that
says that pony rules and Eagleton drools
well now you're just being nasty so as
we know spring hunting season is upon
us uh anyway here's the info about the
new licensing
system um Jerry I don't I don't think
your computer is plugged in I'm sorry
guys just got to power up first thing we
should have is my graph about the season
what wait a minute no that is not the
graph that's a picture from my vacation
to mun you went on a vacation and you
chose Muny Indiana yeah my wife and I B
time I'm sure is myy Tom m is a lovely
city anyway hunting and fishing season
is winding down okay and we all know
that it's already closed season on twout
so
now I said twout instead of trout it
happens to everyone my marbles are full
of mouth
today you know what has anybody seen my
glasses I don't even think I
[Music]
can
[Applause]
and entertainment 720 thank you so much
for that amazing intro Leslie hi folks
my name is Tom hord and I'm here to tell
you a little bit about paon E's Premiere
entertainment and multimedia
conglomerate entertainment
720 where dreams come to come
true how about we watch this brief
promotional film
what entertainment 720 has been a
picture of this community since June Tom
listen to me turn that off or give me
the remote right now this short can you
let it play please you're lucky that
Martin kernston is here cuz you're going
to need another
nipple I can't reveal my identity
because of various corporate enemies but
suffice it to say I run a fairly popular
social networking site and let's face it
booking e720 was the smartest decision I
ever made I hope you liked the
story I invented Facebook
thank you all so much for joining me
today I have two questions for you one
are you ready for the investment
opportunity of a lifetime and two do any
of you have pacemakers or a history of
epilepsy yes both anybody no both all
[Music]
right
ladies JayZ rihana Audrina Patrick John
gosell lady Gaga snooky are these real
people cash war and Dennis Rodman these
are just a few of the celebrities that
wish they could invest in Pony's hottest
club but they
can't and you can for the small price of
only one one one, th th dollar dollar
dollar dollar dollars the only question
is who's going to be my partner Mark I'm
talking to you Donna I'm talking to you
Jerry I'm talking to you mark I'm
talking to you all right so in
conclusion fluoride chemical tiny
genitals misinformation Panic death
Jenny
McCarthy well I don't know councilman
that was a little dry what do you say we
have some fun huh check
this plain water yuck I'm bored then try
[Music]
this what what just happened that water
contains teeth dazzer which makes your
teeth stronger and starts a party in
your
[Music]
mouth what fluorides boring guys boo
welcome to tazzle it's not a chemical
it's an aquatic based social media oral
experience everyone who tweets at T
Dazzle in the next hour will be entered
to win an exciting plain blue t-shirt I
say t you say Dazzle T Dazzle T Daz T
Daz I can't beat them all I have on my
side is facts and Science and people
hate facts and science wait I have an
idea go get Tom run get
Tom yesterday I said some pretty harsh
things about sweds and their great new
product but when I looked at the
research I found some pretty compelling
facts about drink them
that made me change my tune each drinks
is packed with 35% of your daily monop
potassium phosphate requirement MPP is
an emulsifier as well as a plus 7 pH
buffer now I know what you're thinking
what about its molar mass how does
[Music]
36.081001 data that I need to get
through well miss I think we'd all
appreciate it if you just swallowed a
teaspoon of hush think of H2 flow as an
app for your teeth the more flow you
take in the more Sparkle points you get
get enough Sparkle points and you're on
your way to your first Aqua badge
collect enough Aqua Badges and we'll
welcome you to the H2 flow Platinum
Club Miss Perkins Chris Trager has
questioned when my relationship with Ben
Wyatt began I'd like to direct you to
your inbox and specifically an email
entitled yay that's why a and 18 y's and
44 exclamation points yes it is an email
from you oh and there's an attachment M
intriguing could you play the attachment
please
sure in a world on the brink of
financial
meltdown in a town unlike any other an
adorable man with a cute face and the
future president of the United States
what went from being friends to being so
much
more an Ben and I hooked up last
night and I learned how to use iMovie
call me later
bye now we have a special presentation
courtesy of the folks at entertainment
720 hope we brought a change of clothes
cuz your eyes are about to piss
tears you
nasty who are
we where are we going in
life what is the meaning of all of
this these are questions little
Sebastian never had to answer because he
was a
horse instead he just brought brought us
joy and happiness and isn't that the
point good night little
Sebastian
[Applause]
forever Jerry I need to see your
softball pictures here you go Chief wow
good job nice work wait a minute isn't
that that creepy guy Morgan the
pedophile yeah it is my God come on I
didn't know that he seemed
okay we had dinner together guys I don't
know if I made it clear but I don't want
any sex offenders in our Parks catalog I
will Photoshop his face can you
photoshop your life with better
decisions Jerry okay what are we trying
to do with this catalog we're trying to
sell Pony on our summer classes how do
we do that with one perfect captivating
image
April Modern Life where are we running
sometimes what we want is not always
where we are next slide are we alone is
the real winter inside our hearts we are
all struggling for definition in a world
that resists our inquiries okay this
isn't going to work for a number of
reasons one this is a summer catalog two
that was complete gibberish and three
that child looks like it's abandoned so
basically boo next
slide oh God weird how did
that um that's a personal photo that's
shouldn't be this must have you know I
got to say I think that could actually
work as our cover photo I'm cool with
that if you guys are it's a highres
photo I don't know if I have time for
this guys so let's just pick a good
photo okay what do you want Leslie a
picture of parents pushing a kid on a
swing yeah exactly get me that okay I
got to
go what is he thinking why is my cup so
tiny